so we have this one if you are that
comments on every single video asking me
to break down the iPad Mini 6 rumors and
predictions so I'm gonna do just that
with the goal of answering three
questions one is they're really gonna be
a new iPad Mini 6 coming soon - when can
we realistically expect that iPad to get
released and three what features and
changes should we expect to see but
before we start with the first question
and take a look at rumors I want to show
you guys Apple's iPad release timeline
so we can try and understand why and how
Apple releases iPads and by the way we
just got our new Macs tech logo t-shirt
which you can find right below this
video in our merch shelf it all started
with the original iPad which has already
updated four times when the first iPad
Mini showed up in late 2012 and in 2013
Apple updated the mini again but they
chose not to update the iPad because
they just released the first gen iPad
air so they probably didn't want it to
clash with the iPad in 2015 in 2016 the
iPad pro was released and at that point
Apple stopped updating the iPad air
because the price points would clash and
they also wanted all the attention to go
to the iPad pro for the next couple of
years while later releasing new budget
iPads for the lower end market and
finally in 2019 they brought back the
iPad air and the iPad Mini and the main
reason why they did that was because
they finally raised the price of the
iPad pro to $800 leaving enough of a gap
to reintroduce the iPad air for $500 and
the very similar iPad Mini for $400
so now Apple has finally created an iPad
for every price point and market
maximizing the potential for sales so
the point of all of this is to show you
guys that we should expect Apple to move
forward with this strategy and continue
offering this complete lineup going into
the future and one important thing we
can learn from this timeline
that every single time an iPad Mini gets
released it's always alongside another
iPad release every single time and it's
also very important to notice that Apple
is currently going through a
modernization phase which started with
the 2018 iPad pros modern design there
are tons of rumors of Apple completely
redesigning the iMac to look more like a
current iPad pro and the reason it makes
sense for them to do that is because
they're switching over to their own
custom ARM chips so that big of a change
deserves a new design and then there's
the 16 inch macbook pro which was
redesigned with slimmed down modern
bezels and rumors of Apple doing the
same with the 14 inch macbook pro next
year not only that but apple's upcoming
iphone 12 is also rumored to be getting
iPad pro like square edges and there are
so many rumors of the iPad air getting a
larger display and square edges as well
so it seems like Apple is sweeping
through their entire lineup within a
short period of time reducing bezels
increasing display sizes and redesigning
their devices so they all look very
similar to each other based on the new
square edge design and because we're
expecting a newly redesigned iPad air to
get released soon potentially within a
few months it wouldn't make sense for
Apple to keep the iPad Mini the same
with the old design for very long so
let's get into the rumors to see if and
when we should expect the iPad Mini 6
the first rumors we saw came in March
with the very reliable analyst mingsha
Kuo who noted that Apple is going to
release a bunch of mini LED display
Apple devices this year including a new
7.9 inch iPad Mini however there were
many rumors pointing to this mini LED
technology being delayed until the first
half of 2021 and in May mingsha quote
changed his expectations for the iPad
Mini to get released in the first half
of 2021 and at the same time he
mentioned that we should expect a new
10.8 inch iPad which is most likely the
iPad air
to get released later this year and only
a couple of weeks ago we heard another
rumor from digit times that said the
same thing a 10.8 inch iPad air coming
this year and a new iPad Mini in the
first half of next year alongside a new
12 point 9 inch iPad pro so based on
those rumors we can answer the first
question and say yes
the iPad Mini 6 is coming for sure and
in less than a year and as far as the
timing since we know that the iPad Mini
always gets released alongside a
different iPad there are two
possibilities either the iPad Mini will
get released alongside the air later
this year
maybe in October or November or it'll
get released alongside the iPad pro
coming next year which is the most
likely option since mingsha Kuo believes
it'll come with a new mini LED display
which is now apparently delayed to 2021
and because both he and digit times are
expecting a 2021 release date it's most
likely that the iPad Mini 6 will be
released in the first half of 2021 and
now let's address the last question
which features and specs should we
expect to see well if it does get
released next year we can almost
certainly expect it to come packin a new
mini LED display and the rumors are also
pointing to the display size being at
least 8 inches instead of 7.9 and the
only way it makes sense to do this is if
Apple gets rid of the physical home
button on the iPad Mini and to do this
Apple has two options either add face ID
or implement an under display
fingerprint sensor which has been
rumored for a while now now there is the
chance that Apple may choose to reserved
face ID for their higher-end iPads so
it's really tough to call right now and
if Apple does make the display larger
and get rid of the home button we can
expect the display to have rounded
corners and the sides of the iPad to be
squared off to match the new modern
styling of the current iPad pro and the
future iPhone 12 models and as far as
the internals we should accept
the iPad Mini 6 to come with the same
new 5 nanometer a 14 ship with 4 gigs of
RAM as we expect to come in the iPhone
12 and we should also expect it to come
with a hundred twenty eight gigs of
storage at the base price which is
expected to come to even the cheapest
iPhone 12 rumors are also pointing to it
sticking with the Lightning connector
just like the iPhone 12 but we should
definitely expect it to get Wi-Fi 6 and
maybe even sub 6 5g connectivity for the
LTE models and as far as the price it
could very likely stay at the same $400
unless Apple decides to raise the price
of their entire iPad lineup in 2021 by
maybe $50 to make up for inflation and
the more expensive mini LED displays so
hopefully you learn something new from
this video and if you did be sure to
check out our new max tech t-shirt
designs right below this video and click
that circle above to subscribe for more
videos coming soon thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next one
[Music]